Here's a quick refresher on the memory hierarchy
of a processor. As you know, between the CPU
and the main memory there are several levels of
caches. And typically these days, you may have it
up to three levels of caches between the
CPU and the memory. And the, the nature of
the the memory hierarchy is that, you can have
something that is really fast, a small amount of,
or really slow, and big amount of. And, and
so all of these choices that are in between are
really in between the two extreme choices of an L1
cache and the main memory. The disparity in the CPU
cycle time and the main memory if you take the
disparity between the CPU and the main memory, it's more
than two orders of magnitude today, and it's only growing.
So any hiccup that the CPU has in not finding
data or instructions that it needs to execute the
currently running thread in the caches and it has
to go all the way to the memory, is
bad news in terms of performance. So what this
suggests is that in picking the, the next thread
to run on the CPU, it'll probably be a
very good idea if the scheduler picks a thread
whose memory contents are likely to be in the caches.
If not in the L1 cache, at least in the L2 cache. If not
in the L2 cache, at least in the L3 cache. So that it doesn't have
to go all the way to the memory in order to get the instructions
and data for the currently running thread.
So that's an important point to think about.